en los dos vídeos anteriores estábamos
hablando acerca de este ejercicio que
tengo aquí de este ejercicio de
optimización con restricciones donde
queremos maximizar esta función que
tengo aquí x cuadrada por james pero
teníamos una restricción
queríamos que x y james estuvieran en el
conjunto que cumplieran que x cuadrada
más de cuadrada sea igual a 1 que
vivieran en el círculo unitario y
terminamos trabajando con un
razonamiento bastante geométrico y
agradable hasta que por fin llegamos a
estas ecuaciones que tengo aquí estas 3
ecuaciones y ahora en este vídeo no
tenemos más que resolver estas
ecuaciones así que voy a empezar con la
primera déjame ponerle nombre voy a
empezar con la primera justo por aquí
tengo
que 2x
esto es igual a 2x lambda estás de
acuerdo lambda por 2 x es dos veces x
lambda ahora de aquí puedo dividir entre
2 x xi dividido entre 2 x llegarían a
que siempre tiene que ser igual a lambda
y ojo aquí solamente falta aclarar una
cosa estoy diciendo que x no puede ser
igual a 0 porque si x fuera igual a 0
entonces no podremos dividir entre 2 x
de ambos lados de esta ecuación y ahora
puede utilizar esta nueva información
que acaba de obtener aquí en mi segunda
ecuación esta es mi segunda ecuación y
si utilizo key es igual a lambda me
quedaría que x cuadrada es igual a
lambda pero en lugar de lambda voy a
poner game
james que multiplica a 210 o dicho de
otra manera aquí puedo obtener que x
cuadrada es igual a 2 veces de cuadrada
muy bien esto lo obtuve de la primera
ecuación
esto lo obtuve de la segunda ecuación y
ahora puedo utilizar esta información en
nuestra tercera ecuación que era justo
esta que tengo acá esta es nuestra
tercera ecuación porque si x cuadrada es
igual a dos veces y cuadrada entonces
esta tercera ecuación me quedaría de la
siguiente manera me quedaría como x
cuadrada pero x cuadradas dos veces de
cuadrada dos veces y el cuadrado más
cuadrada igual a 1 y de aquí ya puedo
obtener el valor de jeff porque si
supuestos 2 voy a obtener que tres veces
de cuadrada es igual a 1 o dicho de otra
manera ya cuadrada es igual a
entre 3 o de aquí puedo concluir que
bien va a ser igual a más o menos la
raíz cuadrada de un tercio ok
este es un valor importante es uno de
los valores que buscábamos y por lo
tanto lo voy a atrapar en un rectángulo
muy bien ya tengo el valor del yen pero
ahora nos falta el valor de x bueno
puede utilizar esta información de kim
en esta ecuación que tengo acá si
sabemos que x cuadrada es igual a dos
veces ya cuadrada y ya cuadrada es igual
a un tercio entonces de aquí voy a
obtener que x cuadrada es igual a 2 por
un tercio es decir dos tercios luego
dicho otra manera x va a ser igual a más
menos la raíz cuadrada
dos tercios de lujo entonces esta es
otra información importante porque acabo
de encontrar otras dos x que están en
las soluciones de estas tres ecuaciones
y podrá escribir cuánto vale lambda
cierto me quiere decir en el caso en el
que es igual a lambda entonces lambda
valdría más o menos la raíz cuadrada de
un tercio pero lo que en realidad
queremos no es el valor de lambda
si no son puntos que nos den la
respuesta del ejercicio de restricción
original recuerdas lo que nosotros
buscamos es maximizar maximizar esta
función que tengo aquí y usando la
información que obtenemos no encontramos
cuatro puntos donde maximizamos esa
función que buscamos pero lo que sí nos
dan son cuatro posibles soluciones las
posibles soluciones son las siguientes
puedo tener x igual a la raíz positiva
de dos tercios
dos tercios como la raíz positiva de un
tercio ok
este es un punto ahora también tengo
otro punto que se ve como la raíz y es
negativa de dos tercios dos tercios coma
la raíz positiva de un tercio este sería
otro punto que nos interesan tenemos
también la posibilidad de tener la raíz
es positiva de dos tercios coma
la raíz negativa de un tercio esta es
otra posibilidad y por último tenemos
una cuarta posibilidad tenemos un último
punto donde tendría la raíz negativa de
dos tercios como la raíz negativa de un
tercio y bueno esta sería mi último
punto de estos cuatro puntos donde lo
que sí sabemos es que son cuatro puntos
donde las curvas de nivel
gentes ahora no forzosamente todos
maximizan la función de hecho vamos a
buscar cuáles de estos maximizan la
función y para encontrar cuáles de ellos
maximiza la función sería muy bueno
reescribir de aquí de nuevo mi función
la recuerdas la función con la que hemos
estado trabajando es la función de x de
una función multi variable que era igual
a x cuadrada por jeff muy bien entonces
estamos maximizando esta función así que
podríamos insertar estos cuatro puntos
aquí en esta función y ver para qué
valores obtenemos el valor más grande de
esta efe de x tiene pero también podemos
analizar un poco la función y decir mira
x cuadrada esta parte de aquí siempre va
a ser positiva entonces ésta siempre es
positiva por lo tanto no importa si le
ponemos la raíz cuadrada positiva o la
raíz cuadrada negativa obtenemos un
valor positivo
aquí bien puede ir cambiando en tres el
positivo y negativo
depende del signo que le metamos si le
metemos un valor negativo entonces esta
función sería negativa y lo que queremos
es el máximo así que simplemente voy a
decir que ninguno de los puntos donde ya
sea negativa puede ser el máximo ya que
sería un valor positivo x cuadrada por
un valor negativo así que éste no puede
ser el máximo y éste tampoco puede ser
el máximo y ahora como yo sé que estos
dos si me van a dar un valor positivo
entonces puedo calcular fácilmente
cuánto valdría efe de xy aquí
efe de estos dos puntos
efe dm x que maximiza bien que maximizan
bueno va a ser igual a x cuadrado
que ya sabemos que es dos tercios
tercios que multiplican ayer pero ya
siempre valen la raíz de un tercio
entonces que multiplican a la raíz de un
tercio esto es lo que valdrá mi función
en estos dos puntos que hacen que mi
función se maximiza y justo esto nos da
la respuesta final ahora lo único que
quiero recalcar es que todo esto que
hicimos toda esta álgebra que hicimos
fue importante en claro pero lo más
importante de este ejercicio de
optimización con restricciones es
introducir esta idea del multiplicador
de lagrange ya que nos ayudó a encontrar
el gradiente de una función restringida
y luego hacer que estas dos fueran
proporcionales una a la otra ésta es la
clave del problema y luego el resto de
todo esto fue simplemente aplicar cosas
de álgebra ammán resolver ecuaciones y
encontrar estos puntos fue un montón de
trabajo y de detalles mínimos lo cual
bueno también es importante para obtener
la respuesta correcta así que ya está a
continuación en lo sigue
videos vamos a ver algunos ejemplos más